thank you so hi everyone
my name is roman and i welcome you to my
talk called the domain driven ui here at
ndc
oslo or online or whatever so it's a
catchy title
another possibility would have been full
stack event sourcing which is also
pretty catchy and
it's it's i hope it lures you or it
lured you here to
to this talk so i hope to that you get
something out of this so first of all
who am i
um at the moment first and foremost i'm
the father of now almost six years old
twin girls
and and also um a pretty happy husband
but and my wife is always
angry that she's not on this image but
the reason why why it's there is is
basically
my kids are basically learning all day
long at the moment
and i really like this and i'm also a
type of person that
is basically learning and trying to
learn a lot and
i like to to oh i'll learn best when i'm
actually
um sharing my my content and and sharing
what i have learned
and i try to do it with writing but i'm
really bad at writing and i
really can't do it in a nice way so this
is why i started a youtube channel
called the devil
where i'm basically talking a lot about
f-sharp
and event sourcing and a lot of other
topics in there
so if you go there later on i would be
very happy and also i started an f sharp
meet up
but then corona came and we started an f
sharp
online meetup which basically turned
into
f sharpconf which is a full day
conference about f sharp which was
happening
last week last friday so it's also on
youtube i will post it
in the slack later on if you haven't
seen it i think it was a really nice
conference
you need to skip the first 30 minutes
because it was we had horrible technical
problems
but so people started to call it
actually echo conf
so but i think in the end we got it
sorted out and we have really nice and
and awesome awesome talks there and and
also this is a really nice way to share
share what what you have learned and and
how you can actually collaborate with
people i think
so the question now that you know who am
i who i am is
who are you so normally i see the
audience
and i don't do it um but you're here and
and you're using
you're here even though it's an online
conference and i'm not i'm not sure if
if you're wearing any pants or anything
so i don't know but i'm pretty sure
because you're here
you're actually beautiful so thanks for
being here um at first and
and i think you are here at such a
conference
and i'm trying to learn a lot of stuff
so i think you're pretty
curious person whoever you are so this
is one of my
foundations as well so i think we're a
bit alike here so
again thanks for being here so let's
start with the actual content
so this is
a classical three-tier architecture
for building software right i left out a
lot of the technical stuff
like facades and all this stuff but this
is basically what we all know
when we talk about three tier software
architecture
so we have a persistence layer we have a
domain layer
and we have a user interface and
a lot of systems look like this so we
have
a between the persistence and the domain
there is some kind of om
object relational mapper like hibernate
or doctrine or whatever
language you're using and then you have
some kind of crafty interface
create read update delete which is
basically
um the whole system and the question now
is
where recites the logic in those systems
so where do we find the logic
of course we need to find the logic
in the domain this is normally where all
the behavior should actually
reside on but in those systems
there are other places where the actual
logic can reside so for example
uh in my experience a lot of times or
the the logic you can find a lot of
logic in the persistence layer
so you have stored procedures or some
triggers or something else
in there and it's really hard to
refactor the thing out
if if you're switching a database or
you're moving a system or you're
upgrading a system
in the slides i'm sorry to interrupt
we're not seeing your screen
you're not uh we yeah sorry for jumping
and we tried to notify the crew but
oh man this is really bad i'm so sorry
um
that's the wrong one i'm sharing this
thanks for for
announcing really sorry about this
um better
yeah we missed all your beautiful
pictures that you were talking about at
the start
okay
um i just i i just want to show you who
are you so this is the
basic little beautiful picture up there
so
and and also if you want to see this
these are my kids and the devil and they
have sharp conf
so and so let's get back to
get let's get back to the actual content
so we have this here
i'm so sorry about this um so
and then we have a lot of logic also in
the user interface and this is
sometimes very hard because um you have
a lot of cruddy stuff in there and you
need to know what is actually happening
and you really don't want this because
you're normally your your
logic should only be in in the domain
right
but there's also one other place where a
lot of logic in those systems resides
and this is basically the user right
so in in a lot of systems a lot of the
logic
that we're actually need to know or that
that
actually is necessary to run such a
system is within the head of a sister
of the user so the user needs to know
where we can actually start with the
stuff and how we can actually do all
this
so one notion or one a couple of ideas
to actually
um change this came into when when we
were talking about technical patterns of
of domain driven ui um especially with
cqrs and event sourcing so i guess
it's cqrs and event sourcing are not the
newest topics anymore so
when i was talking about this four years
ago with seacrest and event sourcing not
too many people
have raised their hands when i said who
who use the cqrs system who has heard
about this
who use this introduction but still
i think a lot of people haven't really
touched it
and so i'm giving a quick introduction
in into the topic so what is event
sourcing
so event sourcing has the notion that
events
are fundamental for
our business processes so domain events
so
the that domain events are actually
describing
what is actually happening in our system
and it's basically the notion that we
are able to describe all the business
processes
or everything that happened in our
business with domain events
and and if we have this notion if we
have this idea
then we can see say okay let's actually
model
our business with events with domain
events
yet let's actually use those
use those events as the basis for our
model
and if we are there we can also say if
we already have those events
let's build a software which have
which has those events as the foundation
as its foundation
so use so build our software with the
events as real as the fundament of
everything
and if we're there we're almost at event
sourcing but
but what we really need the the next
step in there
is to basically say we don't persist any
state
in our system what we are persisting
are only the events because this is all
that matters this is
this is the main thing that we need for
our businesses
and we don't need need to store any
state only those events
and if we have this we have basically
event sourcing i know this is
very um
a very easy description but but this is
the basic notion of this
and if we have something like this what
what what really event sourcing is
giving us
is that we are actually never um losing
the intentions of the business
so if we have a if we have a database
query something like
update customer set street equals baker
street
in some kind of relational database
why are we doing this and what should we
do after we have done this
so there is no clear intent in here
why we were actually changing the street
of this
specific customer so we can scratch this
and we can say well yeah it might be
that the customer moved
and that's why um to a new street
baker street and for example if the
customer moved
to a different city or to a different
place and we're running a gym or
something
we might want to send them a voucher or
her a voucher
that so so that the the person can go to
the next place with with this new
voucher
but what if we have actually
only corrected the address so there was
only
a mistake that that was happening there
so
in this case the customer is living
there for quite some time now right
so we don't need to send any new
vouchers or any new leavelets or
whatever
so this this is a bit big difference um
when we are actually trying to capture
the event and this is what event
sourcing is really good for
so i think that event sourcing is
awesome and i think
there are a lot of times a lot of
criticism about event sourcing
especially in the last couple of years
last one two years but still i think if
it's done right
it helps you tremendously so you have no
database scheme in there
there's also the the promise of not
having any migrations which is nice but
sometimes you need to think of migrate
your events as well
if you have different versions of your
events but still you have no database
scheme and why i think this is really
nice
is that the data structure that whatever
data structure you're using for storing
for persisting your state
so be it a relational database in new
sql database
uh document database whatever it does
not affect your information model
so your your data model does not affect
your information model
at all you're only talking about the
business and this is what i think
is really really important another thing
is
that we have no loss of information due
to destructive database actions
so a typical destructive database action
is a delete right
a delete or an update as we have just
seen so we're
just we're distracting um
[Music]
information within our database but i
think
so of course the truncate table is also
a destructive action and we don't want
to really do this in production if we're
not sure about this
but what i think is that also a
also an insert is basically a
destructive action because if we
have just what we have just seen the
last slide is
what we are what we are losing here is
again the intent we don't know why
we were actually inserting anything
we don't need to we don't have this
impedance mismatch of
of having to map our objects
our aggregates to specific tables which
is really nice
and it's it's it's really it's not
really easy but it's at least
possible to have a different
interpretation of the past
so which is really nice so if we have a
new use case in our system which is
basically
just a report for specific data
and we have the whole history of events
in our system
since since the beginning of our system
we can actually use those events
projected this into another
report or into into another form and we
can actually
use this new um use case just right away
which is really nice
what i really love about event sourcing
is what if scenarios and this is what
is also coming later in the talk so with
what if scenarios you can
really in a really nice way say let me
just
see how my system would look like
if i would do just this and this this
and this and this
which is really nice and and how this is
done in in my case here
um is shown later but but this is a
really nice way which is
hard to to get done with a relational
database where you need
things like shadow tables maybe or
something that actually mimic
the whole data structure and i think
that testing becomes the testing of the
domain logic not testing of your
infrastructure that's a completely
different
topic i'm not going to talk about here
but testing of your
um of your domain model becomes really
easy
with event sourcing so if we have event
sourcing
we are only storing the events
as the state in our system so if we
use only this we might get a problem
because for every information we
actually want to get out of the system
we need to rerun the whole event stream
and project into
different things and this is where
another
kind of architecture fits in really
nicely which is basically
cqrs so the secrets is called um
or is an abbreviation for command query
responsibility segregation coined by
greg young a couple of years ago
the term which basically means
that we don't have we don't have the
same data model
for our read site and our right side
so the right side is what we mean with
right side is
[Music]
that this is the side where our domain
logic our behavior resides
this is the state that we are actually
storing
to know in which state our whole system
is so this is the right site
and the read site is basically
whatever kind of information we want to
show for example to the user
this whatever page we want to show
whatever we want to project into
something and
and show and use as the basis for the
for new decisions a user can actually
make
and in classical systems these models
are the same
which basically means we need to
optimize for do two different things
right we need to optimize for the right
and we need to optimize for the read and
this is where then those
first second third whatever normal forms
of relational database come into play
so you always need to find a balance
between
let's make it easy for right let's have
it fast for
let's have fast rights and let's have
don't
let's not have too much duplication in
our rights so if i have a first name
somewhere
i don't want to have it in another table
again because if i update it
in one place i need to update it in
another place and i need to have
mechanisms that make
sure that this will never get out of
sync but on the other hand on the read
side
i don't want to have a lot of joints i
don't want to have
so many queries to get some information
my ideal way would be just to
to have a select star from table and
have exactly the information what i need
so here duplication is really good
because i don't want to have three four
or five different tables where i
aggregate all the information from so
what we have here is is a picture of a
cqrs system
so we have here i may start the laser
pointer
so we have here the command side
um and here we have our domain model and
in this case we have down here we have
the user interface a command comes in we
have a command handler
that is doing something and in here we
can also do cqs without event sourcing
but in here it's already in there
so we have the domain model that
actually creates
some events and these are stored with an
append only store
into our database and
if we have a new command coming in we
just get all the events that are
necessary for this
replay then in some way which is still
pretty fast even if you have thousands
of events
and you can make your decisions but for
the right side it's completely different
because we
have our events in here and whenever a
new event comes in there
we are actually projecting into
different read models
so we have we can have 1 2 10 20
different read models we can have a read
model
for every specific use case if we have a
um basket where people can actually
buy stuff in there for example we can
have just a
a a read model for the list of things
that
people have bought that people have
bought in the past
and we can have specific database table
or whatever data structure we actually
needing
to to represent this and if we for
example need some kind of
friendship algorithm we could use
something like a graph database or we
could use something like a document
database whatever fits the use case best
and and the great thing is that
we can create those things we can
destroy them is
if there is the bug in there we can just
replay all the relevant event
events again which is then really nice
and this never affects
our actual domain model so in here we
have only
an append only store which is really
fast and there is no logic anymore in
in the in the persistence layer
and on the other side we actually get we
can create
all the um information
that we want so this is basically
the the main idea of cqrs
so the question is now how can we
actually implement
information how can we actually get
those
information out of those events so this
is this
this is this side here of of our cqrs
system so let's say
let's say we have a conference planner
we're actually organizing a thing like f
sharp conf or
or the ndc oslo in here and we have
actually a cons planner
and what we have here is it's it's
really not the nicest ui but the idea
here is basically we have a couple of
abstracts people have
sent in abstracts and we are the
organizers of such a conference and
we can vote for we we can give different
points or we
can say veto i really don't want that
speaker on my conference
and a lot of people can do this and then
in the end we can finish a voting period
and whoever has the most points is
actually accepted
to the conference so this is a this is
um something that we want
to show to the user right
so first of all again the events
as i said are the foundation for
everything
and if we're using f sharp or any kind
of ml language or any kind of language
that actually has the notion of
discriminated unions
which are basically if you have never
worked with such a language
enums on steroid so which basically
looks like this
so we have an event type and we have all
the possibilities of events
that actually were happening in our
system
and in there each case can wrap
different kind of information
it doesn't really matter in here what
are you wrapping in there but
you can do whatever um so the events are
the foundation for this
but if you say events are the foundation
i think it's a it's a small side rant
maybe
i think you should really um think of
let me just get my mouse back here sorry
so that you're not
um interrupted all the time um if if you
say events are the foundation you
really need to make events the
foundation for your system
what i mean with this is what i see a
lot of times also if i go to
two different companies and work talk to
different
developers is that they model
errors in the domain as exceptions
so that if something is not going right
within our domain
we use exceptions for this and i think
this is a really
big problem because why is this
exceptional if something is not working
in our domain i'm not talking about out
of memory
network errors um your your rate
storage just was just blown away
whatever this is an exception and you
really
need to to raise a panic there but if
there is something expected in our
behavior
why should we actually model this with
stack traces
our customers don't know about
stacktraces i don't
want to know about stack traces right so
if we are in a in a in a conference
and i want to add an organizer to a
conference
what should happen if the organizer is
already added to the conference
what should the conference do just get
up and flip the table and say i'm i'm
stopping here this is not really
what what we want to have right so i
think it's really important to also
model
the the arrows that that are expected
there are not exceptions
in our domain in this case i used a
specific error case here
and we have a couple of error things in
here where we say okay the conference
was already scheduled
um the organizer was already added to
the conference
etc etc and this is really nice and this
this can really be modeled in a nice way
i think
so okay so again let's let's
build a read model for this site that we
have actually that i have just shown you
so if we have this read model
again it's f sharp and if you have no
clue about f sharp
um it should be still possible to read
this so for example here we have a call
for papers that is either not
opened opened or closed we have a voting
period which is in progress or finish
and in here this is basically then the
type of the read model
ddo data transfer object it's the type
of the read model for
one of our pages for example and in here
we have a
id title whatever and this is what we
want to create out of
our events so the question is how can we
get this
and we use projections for this so
projections are
things that have basically two parts the
first one is an
init case which is just a state so for
example an
empty conference and the second one is
an
update function that takes a new state
and takes an event
and returns a new state and if you write
this in f-sharp it can look like this we
have a projection in here
these are generic type parameters as you
have in in java or c-sharp as well
and then we have the init and the update
is a function from state
to event and state and greg young
put a tweet out like now seven years ago
already you want to learn event sourcing
it's just a function from state to event
and state
and returns a state and this is what's
basically what he was talking about
right
so of course it's not always that easy
but this is the main notion
out of this so if we have such a
projection in here
and we have here a projection which is
the initial conference
and the update is an apply function in
here
then we say okay whatever event comes in
this is pattern matching it's basically
a switch case if you have never seen
this
if this is the conference scheduled then
which which gives me the conference then
i just return it and if i have an
organizer added to the conference i just
put this into the list of organizers
so there bit by bit i am actually
updating
my current read model and here i'm just
basically using
i get a given history which is a list of
events
and then i run all of them each bit by
bit through them and build the complete
read model so this is the right side how
we can actually do this
i'm not talking about how we can store
this here this is actually how to just
build those read models
so now we want to implement the behavior
site
so in here we have a command handler and
then the domain
and we get some events in here as i said
and then we need to create some new
events in our system
so again we have such a discriminated
union here where we say okay we have
these are all the types of commands that
can
actually happen in our system so we can
schedule a conference
change a title whatever whatever and
when we get
such a command in our execute function
we also get the event list for the given
conference
and then we say okay if we want to
schedule a conference we call the heddle
scan
handle schedule conference function or
the handle change title conf
function or the handle reopening voting
per unit function or whatever there is
in there
and if we have this we need to somehow
take the history
make a conference state out of it and
then call the reopen
a voting period function in here and
again here
then we can this is where our
constraints are so if we are an
object-oriented language this will would
um reside in an
object aggregate where you have all the
functions or methods in there
here it's a functional language so we
just have functions and we say okay if
the conference call for papers
is closed and the conference voting
period is finished
then we say no you can't really reopen
the voting period because oh no then we
say okay
the voting period was just reopened but
in all other cases the finishing was
denied because the call for papers was
not closed
for example and the question is how we
can actually
get this conference state well we have
just
talked about projections and also
in in the domain logic we can use those
projections to get
to a current state of our conference
which is really nice
and so in here we just return
a list of events that are happening
when some command was actually done
and if we're doing all this what comes
really
out what what comes out really nicely is
that we can
test our domain logic in a really nice
way especially
if we're using this bdd style testing
so bdd style testing i'm not talking
about bdd in general here and what it
means
to actually live this bdd style of
creating software
but the bdd style testing what i'm
talking about here is
is this given when and then so given a
specific precondition
when a specific action comes into the
system then we get this kind of outcome
and with normal systems we need to
this precondition we need to set up our
system to actually
have a state from where we can get to
to another state so we might set up some
mocks and
some data structures in there the really
cool thing with event sourcing is
that we only need events
so given a set of events 1 or 10 or 15
when a specific action so for example a
command occurs
then we expect a set of events
and this is this is really nice we don't
need to think of
mocking we don't need to think of of
doing all this stuff
this is this is really a pleasant um way
of actually writing
those tests and if you have a language
like f-sharp
you can also write a pretty nice dsl for
this
so we can basically translate this
directly to code we can
say given the call for paper was opened
copper paper closed and the voting
period was finished
when i finished the voting period then i
expect that the finishing was denied
and it was an error so actually this can
be shown to business experts right you
can talk about this
with business experts and this is really
cool
all right enough of this so if we have
this thing here
and we we get rid of
of our old persistence and we use an
append only event store in there
we can actually get rid of the
persistence
in our system which is uh
not the persistent in our system the
logic in our system sorry
we don't want to get rid of the
persistence at all so if we have a look
at this
this basically looks like a ring right
so this is we have this nice pattern in
there and and this is really this is a
ring of power
you know this is really the most
powerful ring of software development we
have ever seen and we are so happy that
we have it
right so it's really weird it's really
awesome that that we can actually
um use this thing and we want to use it
everywhere but the big problem is
that um so everything is cool reads are
optimized rights are optimized behavior
on the back end is one place
but the the problem is
we still look shitty and no one wants to
play with us right
and our our front end the thing that our
actual users are touching
we might have a big problem with this
because it's it's only a back-end
uh thing back-end architecture so
we tried a lot so we tried winforms wpf
i
i'm more from a work background so we
had angular react redux
and a lot of things in there um
and a lot of things were nice angular
had
especially angular one it it's it's no
ancient stuff but
but still it was for me it was this
first way of two-way data binding i said
change something here the model has
changed then i changed the model and
this has changed and this is so
awesome until it's not awesome anymore
and you get
you get cascading updates and you don't
know why something is changing because i
just
changed something here and suddenly my
my whole
thing you you can't really follow this
anymore and
um also with redux which has a really
nice architecture
things like immutability are not
enforced and you get a lot of problems
with this especially when having side
effects and all this stuff so
we were really thinking of man are we
really that bad with user interfaces
or is javascript really this bad
language that everyone is talking about
and is this really that hard
and so and and then for me a guy came
around
um which i really admire who i really
admire
which is evan sheplerkey and he said
basically
developing good user interfaces is not
hard because javascript is so bad
but because user interface design is
actually a hard problem
and he came around not only with an
architecture but with a whole language
which is called elm and for me
this was basically you know
welcome to the promised land so here i
am this is how you should
this is how i want to write my user
interfaces from here on
this is basically a couple of years ago
this happened and
i'm still there to be honest so and and
one
thing is with elm what i really admire
is this notion of tie your hands to free
your mind you can't do
everything all the time you it's really
hard to
do to do workarounds in some way and
it's a functional language
also immutability everywhere is really
nice
so but what what i want to talk about
here is not elm
what i want to talk about here is the
elm architecture or
model view update so mvu and and now a
couple of weeks ago microsoft introduced
maui which they also take the
term mvu for which i don't think it's
mvu at
all because this mvu structure is
basically
based on the notion of immutability so
in their model view update i'm going to
explain this now why why is it called
like this
we have the model so the model are only
types it's not the domain model
it's the model of our application of our
front-end application
so we have only types in there it's only
the structure
there's no behavior in there and the
important thing is
it's the single source of truth so this
is where
all the information about my software
needs to be
there's no other other place in my
frontend application
and then we have the view
which is a declarative description
on how my front end should look like
um dependent on the current state of the
model
so it's not actually changing anything
it's just if my model looks like this
my view should actually look like this
and this is in the back end in the back
it's it's implemented with
virtual dom so what is happening here
whenever we get a new model
um which is always because immutability
it's always a new model it's not a
mutated
um state object whatever
we are rendering a new view and on the
back
we make some diffing so that it's still
fast
if we create a whole new view so we are
not switching the whole dom
if we are in the web case for example
whenever the user
is doing something then a message is
sent
to the runtime or to a mailbox so if you
if you
know the actor pattern it's basically a
mailbox in there but you can just call
it the run time
so the if the user clicks on something
there is a message sent to the runtime
that says
okay messages clicked a message was
clicked or
if you have intent then there user
requested
um the reopening the re opening of a
voting period
so then a message this message is then
sent to an update function
and this is a pure function and this
basically takes
the current state of the model it takes
the message
and it returns a new model
based on the message so based on how the
actual thing
should um work or should look like again
so it's all declarative
it's always if we have the model the
view describes how it should look like
and if we have a message and the model
the update describes
how the new mess the new model should
look like and then this whole circuit
starts
if we only have this this thing would be
nice but it would be completely useless
because we just had like
warming up our cpu there is nothing
happening i can't really send any
http calls over the fire i can't really
have websocket connections i can't
really do anything
that is why based on specific messages
which are called commands that are
coming from the update
it's a command that is going down again
to the runtime to the mailbox
and then the the runtime mailbox
whatever is responsible
for the side effects and whenever a side
effect
is finished like an http call it could
have an error or could some
could be a success then another message
gets back
to the update function and the whole
cycle restarts and this is a really nice
architecture
and the cool thing is that here you know
this is the
this is the dangerous part where things
can go really wrong if you
if you do denial of service to something
and and
or you ha this is just where we're
basically with the side effects recite
where everything can go wrong but this
is handled um on the side of your
really nice um really nice loop
so if you have a look at this again this
would be f sharp in here
um it's basically we have the model
which is just an
int so this is the counter where we
count up and count down it's really easy
um application of course nothing to
really think about but
the messages the only thing that can
actually happen in the system
is increment or decrement nothing else
can actually happen
so in our types we can actually describe
all the things that can happen in our
system
the inner thing so our initial thing is
that our model is
zero and based on the model in here
we have a view that this is a dsl for
html we have a div
with two buttons in there and if i click
i dispatch a message um
that decrements i dispatch the message
decrements if i click on the minus
button and if i dispatch a message
increment if i click on the plus button
and this update function then takes
again what i just said here
the message and the model and returns a
new model so even though there's a plus
in here
the language is immutable so everything
is immutable so it
is returning a new model here and the
whole cycle starts again
because then the new view is rendered
and in here i say
what the current number is if you have a
look at this thing here
how does that what what does this
resemble to
well it's another ring right so we have
another ring of power
and it's i think it's a way more
pure and beautiful ring in there and
because you can build really nice things
for for for your viewing pleasure
actually in there and it's all
pure and immutable and it's really nice
but now we have a problem right
so now we have two rings of power
now uh we have is this shared here all
the time
actually um
um so now we have this
pure ring of power in here um
so this can be a problem
right so this can be a problem because
now we have those two forces
that are actually um might
fight with each other right so they we
have the power here we have the
power on the other side and if there's
those are two teams for example you
can't imagine
the problems that can occur if we're
actually um um having those
those two forces working against each
other each other
so what we actually want in my opinion
is to
to um to marry those
right we want to actually to to actually
bring those together
and and talk and and and and rule
together basically the whole system
but then we have a problem because
they might talk about the same things
and they might talk about in this case
here it's ice whatever
but if we are not having the same model
we we still have um we still have
misunderstandings in our communication
so it might
lead to a lot of frustrating very
frustrating problems in our system and
with our teams
so what we really want to have is to to
bring those two models as close together
as it's actually possible and the
closest thing that we can actually have
together
is um the view
sorry sorry is if if there is only
one model right so if those penguins
talk about fish
um it's pretty clear that they all talk
about fish so the easiest thing would be
if actually everyone is talking
basically about the same model
okay um so
what if if we're actually able to
achieve this
what what could we achieve then in our
system
or how can we use those two rings to
work together
well we have this shared data model here
and in the shared data model we said for
whatever um use case we have
we can actually create a user in a a
read model
so in here so what we could do is we
could use one read model as the basis
for the model of our front-end
application as
the basis for our mvu thing so here
as the model in this case and
this is really nice so then the
projections might be
written only once and then you can reuse
them here to use this as your shared um
thing here for for your front-end thing
and if you're
actually sharing the data types and
might even
share the types and share some of the
logic in there
you can go even a step further so this
would
maybe allow you to use parts of your
domain model
for your update function so just imagine
if your
system um the the network connectivity
of your system goes down
and you really want to actually um
keep working on then what what you need
to do is
somehow um duplicate the the logic from
the back end to the logic of the front
and if you really want to
to see how your system would look like
if you can't really send all the
commands to the server all the time
and get the results so and if you're if
you would be able to do this to share
your information and share your behavior
um then we could actually then we could
actually marry those systems so then we
could actually
use our events of our domain model in
our update function
in here which would be really cool if we
have the right use case for this
so this this is really nice so then we
can actually
rule together the world and and have a
really nice
message based architecture system in
here so
if we do this we still have a problem in
here so not everything is is perfect now
because we're still having the scrub
thing here and
all the thing can be done in a crud way
but then you lose all the
all the nice advantages of event
sourcing of
this nice architecture here so what we
really want is actually we want to get
from a crud crowd-based user interface
where i have just
a couple of radio check boxes in there
whatever
and some save button or update button
to a task-based user interface where i
have specific actions
and i can really make those specific
actions because it's
we have the events we know what um what
the outcome is so we can we can describe
the business operation and then we also
have the command so let's make a user
interface
based on those commands for example i
want to just work
this miss my co-worker marco whoever
knows him i don't want to do this but
yeah this could be a thing and if we
actually do this and have a task-based
user interface in here
we can get rid
as much as possible of the of the domain
logic in the head of the user
because there are only tasks that
actually
needs to be done so it's not if i click
here and then there and right click in
here and then i can actually save this
thing
which is really cool and the domain
logic that
resides in the user interface is
actually good domain logic
because it's shared from with the domain
so it's not something that is duplicated
or or
might deviate after some time and i'm
not talking about the logic
that a select box should open or
something this is completely
a different kind of logic i'm not
talking about here
but the question is this would be really
cool but the question is how
how can we actually do this so the first
thing is yeah we could keep it in sync
manually
but then i think we get a lot of
problems if we have the domain logic
here and the other logic there and we
need to somehow
keep it in sync manually it's really
easy to to deviate and
and have a quick fix here and this is
forgotten somewhere else
so this would be a possibility but might
not be the best one
so another one would to have like a
um code generation
system in your in your system where you
have your back end code and your parsers
and
you somehow generate your font and code
based on the back end code i think
haskell has some nice way to do this and
another line a couple of other languages
as well
but we we are actually going
small part of our system is going that
way and it works well
but there are also other ways so
one way i really love to use is a tool
like fable so it's a
f-sharp to javascript transpiler it
works for
for us it works really really really
well and
it generates basically readable
javascript
and um you don't of course
you need to know javascript for all the
quirks and quarks and whatever happens
on your front end
but still it it helps us tremendously
with with the business logic
um being on the back end and on the
front end and and giving us some
a lot of really nice opportunities and
having not having to use also typescript
but having a really nice
type statically typed front end which is
really cool
so what i'm going to do now is i'm going
to
show you a small prototype how
this could actually work and and what
what you could actually
build with with these kinds of archit
with this kind of architecture in
your mind so this didn't work
um so i hope that you can actually
see my screen it looks good i think
so what we are having here is the con
planner again and here we have two
conference in here the b
sharps and the f sharp conf and we have
a bit of information about the f sharp
confidence conference title
and we have the available slots for the
talk
um we have a couple of organizers it's
me marco green
and dylan is doing nfc oslos he's not
here
which is good then i think and we have
our votings
so in here i can um in here we have
basically
um the possibility to
vote for different talks so i say okay i
want to have from zero to f sharp
um hero for from james i really want to
within this so i voted one one or if i
really want to have this i voted two
and i say no i don't want to work with
him then i voted
um i gave my v2 in here down here you
can then see
okay i have my my commands that are
actually running at the moment to my
server
and in the down here we can see which
events are
actually coming back from the server so
what this thing is actually doing is
when this whole thing started it asks a
read model from the server
it asks it give me the current state
for this conference that can be shown to
a user
so um and from there on
it's it's used to actually display this
to the user but from there on whenever
i'm doing something what is happening
here is
that the actual event is sent back to
the client
and it is then used to reuse the
projection
from the read model because i'm using
this basically i don't want to need to
ask
the read model on the server we can just
stay on the client in here
and and now how this thing should look
like then
and if we have another one here who is
also opening the
sharpconf another client here now
it was asking for the current state of
the read model
which is basically the same
and i need to really get this thing here
off
which is basically the same but whenever
now i do something
in here you can see that this is also
updating because now all the events
um are sent to all the clients via
websocket in this case
to all the clients that are actually
connected so now all the clients are
basically
live and can do um and can update their
read model or their model of this mvu
applications accordingly
which is pretty cool and also it's the
other way around in here
so this is one thing that that is really
nice we don't need to ask to read more
all the server all of the time but what
this allows us now
is to say basically okay if i say here
for example i say finish the voting
period
we see now okay don't sign was accepted
and filing was accepted
um james was not accepted in here if i
re open this
we see this on both things but what i
want to do now is i want to switch
to a what if mode um this could be now
i just want to see how my contours
conference would look like if i have
these words if
is it diverse enough is it do i have the
right people do i have maybe i want to
schedule them
for some rooms so what i could do now
i'm in what if not now
and now i can change my stuff in here i
say okay i want to gain james 2
or vito for down and also the two for
philly
and what we have here now is potential
commands so these are the commands that
might actually be sent to the server and
whenever
i do something here i get the potential
events it's a bug in here actually
there should be all the events in there
it's only showing the last one but
they're all there
and what we're doing we're using now the
same domain logic from the server
to know which events are actually
generated would be potentially generated
on the server
and we can work in a what if mode so if
we say
now make it so like picard you know so
then
all the things are actually sent to the
server
and everything is done here we can i do
this again to make it a bit more clearer
i say this this and here the veto
and then i can say finish or
voting period and then in the end if i
say
make it so we can see that here also the
voting
period is finished this is really nice
and this is
without any kind of shadow data
databases or any kind of thing
we have implemented a really nice
what-if situation
in there which really allows me to check
how my thing would work or if my network
connection goes down
what is also possible um and the last
thing i want to show
what i think is really cool there might
be
and there are always questions about
yeah but what about
but what about if someone else did
something in the meantime and now you
need to have some conflict
resolution because what if two commands
are right
and um then the second the third one was
not a right so there was kind of a
domain error in there
and now everything would be different
than i expected
now you can think of of of some
strategies for for actually fixing this
but what also could be possible is that
we actually say okay
i go here and then i say i do this
and i do that and i do this and then i
also
say i go to organizers and i say okay
dylan should also be an organizer of
this conference
and then i go back and say i finished
the voting period again
and not all oh
okay this is a bad thing okay i can't
really do this
um let's do this here i can't finish the
voting period
because not all organizers have actually
done something
but still i have put my vetoes to all of
the tasks for example
what i do now is i go to organizers and
say okay
now here dylan is the also an organizer
of the conference
but this is now live right so we are
here in a different state now than here
so
we have a deviation in there because now
this is live
so now i can say make it so all
and what is happening now is because
there's one arrow
in in my whole system in in my in my
whole event stream it's basically a
command stream so it's basically a
command batch that i was sending
and because there is one error in there
none of the commands are actually
resulting in different state of the
system
because we have two errors in here
organizers already added to the
confidence and not all
objects have been voted by all
organizers
which is i think a really nice way to
actually
um to actually work with those kinds of
systems so you you can have a
really easy strategy to work with with
actual conflicts
okay so let's go and now this switch
so this should be good um so i think
this is really cool
i really love this i think this is an
awesome kind of
of um actually writing your up
architectures writing your applications
but of course
beware the bias you know this works
really nice and
really cool and now we want to do this
all the time but
you know this notion of if you have only
the only thing you have is a hammer and
everything looks like a nail and
especially if you have such a powerful
hammer you know
if you have thor's hammer in here this
this is
really neat to think about is this the
correct use case for this
if you have a completely different
front-end team
maybe really sharing the code is not the
best one if you have a cross-functional
team
for one bounded context maybe this is
the perfect way to go
but really think about it because even
we saw this one thor movie movie i think
where where this hammer was destroyed so
even the most powerful hammer
can be the wrong tool so
if you got it awesome if you ask what
can i do now so beware
this is a prototype this is not a
production ready thing it's
i think it's the future somehow but but
it's
it's a prototype so the concepts are
working
this thing is not production ready of
course but still
now it would be the time to learn um to
do your stuff
and to do this to ask me questions if
you have any so
first of all sorry for the sorry for the
technical problems in the beginning i i
didn't share my screen
obviously and i don't know if you have
seen your faces all the time and
but i hope that you got something out of
the talk so
thanks a lot the code for this stuff is
within the safe stack repository
um safe stack is is a thing of f sharp
front end to back end and it's called
the safe conf planner
um you can find my my my youtube channel
on
the devol on youtube my twitter handle
is romson
this is a zero because the the over
over's not available anymore github is
ronson with an actual o
so i'd say thanks a lot i don't know if
we have time for questions but
i will be in the chat anyway so thanks
you